citizens of the reject Nation it is John it
is Tara Erickson and we are back for another
first time movie watch yeah this time we're
watching The Punisher that's right 2004's
Marvel film not John Bernthal not Ray
Stevenson not Dolph Lundgren or whoever
else it's Thomas the Jane in the title role are
you excited Tara are you ready to get violent
that's right guys before we get to it
leave a like on the video uh comment
below with your favorite way to punish
people hit the Subscribe button and the
notif oh wait wait yeah hit that subscribe
button and when you do bring that back
that's right people ring the bell for the
real rejects ring the bell for Tara Erickson
also check out La eats drinks terror's online
food Excursion and before we get into this we
got a panel coming up at San Diego comic
books convention Saturday Greg Coy and I
are coming to Comic-Con sdcc 2023 we got a
panel live on Saturday so if you're down in
San Diego be sure to check that out and uh
hey if you want to get the full experience
with us see everything that doesn't make
these reaction highlights come on over
to patreon.com the real rejects where you
can sync up with your own copy watch The
Punisher along with us and without further
Ado I think we're ready for some punishment
thing
and we got the old Marvel bumper with
a little Punisher sprinkled in hey
hey guys do this [Music]
cool opening titles I don't know why
it's giving me like a metal gear Vibe but
it's got that kind of dramatic heft
just classic cool animation [Music]
where's my pickup truck let's do this you need
that sticker in the back window yes about yay
size Mr Astros trust is not gained easily he
doesn't like new faces so tell me why am I looking
flip-flops yeah with a suit Auto
Creek meet my friend Bobby he's
helping me with the finance he's not a
cop neither of those is Liv Schreiber
oh oh
yes now you're speaking his language [Music]
under arrest for the importation
and sale of Contraband firearms
whoa damn this is not my deal I don't even
know these guys [Music] don't point a gun
like that in a standoff people are just
waving guns around like it's NBD I hope
the Punisher wears flip-flops the rest of the
movie well it is Florida it's hot and sticky
I was waiting for that happened who's the kid well
definitely not in the plan but we beat the spread
this isn't football you know sting operations
football same diff or not I mean he looks very fit
he's Robert Saint Howard Saints son uh oh I
can't be good I want to know one thing only
who broken the deal his name is Otto Krieg and
if it's any comfort to Mr Saint he's dead too
well it's not oh oh we got a Travolta a man
who's responsible for my son's death Must Die
oh I told you to never let him out of your sight
Bobby told me to stay it was Bobby's idea he
wanted to go alone thank you for that explanation
now someone bring me Caster Troy more boxes guys
sure the lady Castle oh this was a hard one
this was the last one you're out for good
now you guys can just hang at home and
make out so much making out to catch up on
London's a safe place where we can all be together
no more moving around I promise someday when
you're older will I'll tell you why we had to
move so much so close to a Tony Stark goatee
would you pay in Howard will know everything
there is to know about Otto Creed within 24 hours
oh that was a quick cut yep Puerto Rico
drone shots before there were drone shots
when it was called a helicopter and the man
hanging out of the side of said helicopter
hey Frank is that that uh Candelaria people
around here call him a witch doctor lives
on that island way off the point only one
damn fool I know crazy enough to swim over
there oh I bet that's gonna come back let's
get some Voodoo in here I'm very happy that
you're all here I'm very proud that you're
wrong what is his name and that I love you
salute I lost so much time with both of you
and I'm really sorry hey hey hey I married you
I knew what I was doing and I
do it again oh sweet you and I
we're not lucky we are blessed yes
we are I ship them every couple
his name's Frank Castle oh no she's got the
bureau's London desk no connections dang it he's
leaving for England next week and he's at a family
reunion in Puerto Rico I think you should be there
back and tell Olivia how he died oh boy wait
what kill them too this whole family oh yeah
okay girl every generation you can get your
hands on Kill Them All were selling T-shirts
in town one of them was really scary the guy
in the shop said it Wards off evil spirits
it's really intense oh goodness oh no oh no
yes love it yes uh Wards off bad spirits
I also bought you this Iron Maiden album
is this all their family I
guess kill a lot of people
oh boy oh my God this does feel like a movie
at an earlier time I know we're in 2004 but
something feels like yeah like older sensibility
yeah yeah makes me wonder who directed this like
if they got maybe like an international
action director to come over or something
oh no oh jeez geez why you
go for the old lady first
the grandma start with Mom okay
all right oh man oh oh my gosh oh
jeez
dive over the mini bar oh I'm
gonna blow up some propane tanks
Frank Castle plays games nice he's
a gamer cool he killed Michael Myers
yeah it definitely it was like they didn't
try to hide that that was a full-on dummy
okay oh dang it no damn you umbrella guy what
what yes good job dad like a true Castle
classic trip action it's a good stunt it's like
felt like a real yes and she has a boat too nice
come out oh hey dude totally
just Mission Impossible dead
okay so he cut his cheek all right he's
gonna bleed out over the next several days
whoa whoa whoa that was cool awesome
[Music]
oh my goodness these stunts are
pretty wild that is an amazing
stunt like what they're also taking these
cars suspensions to the absolute limit yeah
oh
oh don't you know it yep
[Music]
oh my god oh my God this is
terrible quite tragic yeah [Music]
[Music]
come on Grandpa's boat hurry hurry
hurry oh my goodness come on honey
oh geez no no just drum in the water
jump in the water jump in the water
oh my gosh I just got pancakes
oh my gosh no way I did not think
oh my gosh where did the truck go oh yeah
where is it is it what the what where's the car
it's right there is it hiding no that's a boat
what what did I do like he got there that late
the car could already what back up and take off I
guess no oh it's down there very long dock okay a
lot of places to hide on this wide open dock now
we must punish oh yeah hey what's the paint man
Wowie
[Music]
knew this was coming Pete
oh okay mother and father send the
regards this time they're not blanks
[Music]
it's an interesting cut
agua in the agua [Music] whoa nice
laughs that's awesome that's a real
explosion this movie is very tangible
ouch God all the blood he must
have lost in there it's like The
Little Mermaid but the horror version
he's with a man the little gun maid
oh the guy that owns a fuel place
is he gonna save him yeah man
bring me some thingama bobbers they crowd
tonight Mr sink you look beautiful little prick
holy [__] Gangland style
I hope they call him Francis
for the rest of the movie it's like
that the punisher's name is Francis
okay now he enjoys being a cook
guys it's right there yeah what what what's
going on here come on man is this how you
you went out of her
girl's best friend
oh dang okay oh yeah all right here we
go hey girl hey a little post-mortar uh
post-murder post murder uh copulation we
call it yeah yeah Sam how long has it been
a few weeks at least a month or two this beard
grows that fast no like three months right
okay
all right pack up your little Arsenal
it is funny that the cops would come
and board it up but leave the guns
I know we'll just leave that there
uh is that the shirt that would be the shirt
oh yeah you're wearing that now now it's badass
enough yeah go with God God's gonna sit this
one out God's Gonna via Khan himself yeah I
got a shirt that's good karma and Wards
off stuff I don't need God and is there
a subtle implication that you know Voodoo helped
preserve his life after being filled with holes
let's go whisking guns Gear Up montage
cool oh my gosh cool cool cool cool it's like
home alone with the grown-up version yeah
this makes you want Italian food Ben Foster you
you are is he talking to himself to your
mother and I this is a mirror I can't wait
did he have a headset on and I didn't see it
ah great guy in the chair
Rebecca Romaine what do you think he does he's
an artist wow my neighbor is an artist so what
do you think he's doing he's doing art stay away
from your Castle I have friends here [__] let's
talk about your friends make your own friends body
I'm not saying no you can't have any of my friends
clever
[Music] he's killing someone
and we're next exactly
alt Universe Sean Annette over here any discussion
of how it changed business involves two cubes
Toro Brothers they control all the prostitution
of gambling wowie whoa they give their dirty
money to Howard Saint transports it in cigarette
boats to his Banks and Grand Cayman Washington oh
my gosh the guy who does Impressions it's
yeah he's my friend I didn't know he's in
this movie dude he's gonna be punishing people
You're Gonna Want to Say Howard Saints Lackey
for the rest of your life I hate the Saints tell
me about them what they do where when why how he
has first tea time five days a week at Tampa
Springs Hawaii Libya every Thursday she works
out gets her nails done and goes to the movies
she only works out on Thursday one day a week
let's not forget Johnny Boy the son you didn't
kill what a putz whoa Clinton's glass yeah with
our 20 years the family conciliary
lawyer CPA and a sadist cancellieri
he's gonna kiss that girl yeah I
thought they were gonna make out
yeah oh he's just threatening him okay are
they gonna make out oh my God yes we saw it
yeah baby I mean I want that guy to die and
all but also I'm happy he's he's yeah it's true
Oh I thought he'd be dragging it what's it
on top of the car those pipe things hilarious
oh I think I might oh nice dude
that's awesome that's awesome
poor guy although I guess anyone
who works at Saint Industries is
a bad person yeah they're all bad it's
part of the hiring process they make
very interesting bad guy yeah yeah
all their employees for Peak irony
whoa yes
get up feel the money okay cool nice the window
oh golly we gotta get some money nice
[Music] happiest day of my life
no good business nice murder to say pay you
for each one or does he get a group rate
discount he gets him in bulk from Costco
I like to purchase six orders of murder
fastest draw on the East Coast but how can
we make him suffer if we can't find him he's
Darius he misses his family and he wants to
die he's asking for help so let's help him
we'd be doing him a service a kindness
we want our money back and we want protection
on the next shipment do you guarantee our money
this time everything I've got can't tell
if they're confident in that answer or not
whoa
[Music] you should leave right
now shut your face you lard ass
that's mean body shame my dude
I'm gonna call it cops damn
hey get out yeah
nice get out yeah cool knives I was
gonna say whack him with it love it
I'm Joan Dave's the one with all the um the
metal they're called piercings we're really
really sucks why did you say that name
all right she just got done with the workout
now she's back in her dress and she's going
to a movie we know it's a Thursday
man buenos dias Pablo Film Festival
is that an exploding fire hydrant all
right or is he just gonna get her a ticket
she left her purse in the car yes
carrying those around in the case aren't those
worth millions what is she doing quitting glass
why do you work for a homophobe man yeah
shame shame I guess there's got to be a
lot more tolerant crime syndicates
out there not with the Saints
oh it's just so nobody else would
park there okay all right smart
I know my Mr glasses as some pulling
into the Wyndham Hotel a couple hours
ago strategically placed Mickey yeah I
was just telling where you been Clinton
without by the pool well Mickey said that he
saw you at the window Mickey should have his
eyes checked a lot of guys around with this
beard morning sir sit down where you like
spin us an outlaw yarn on that their
guitar I feel like it's not a guitar
what else could fit in a guitar case Tara
so my case I can hear what you're thinking
oh you doubt sin fear you
may come back someday [Music]
it's a famous musician he's got such
like Johnny Cash Vibes you like that song
singing at your funeral I mean why does
Harry heck have a problem it's James
did he just like crush his thumb under something
or yeah it's been green and then
now it looks okay oh whoa shazbot
it just fixed this up
come on oh damn it Desperado all right
[Applause]
whoa that's awesome nice
yeah good stunt these cars
[Applause] oh no the car dude
it was so fresh and so clean
you are one dumb son of a [__]
we're gonna have to a gunfight yeah
whoa whoa oh awesome spring loaded nice
good thing Harry heck has a nice vehicle oh
yeah and sustained minimal damage [Music]
whatever could this be [Music]
nicely done cool oh it's not about
money it's about sending a message
yeah nice avenging Spirit shipment of cash
that's what happens
and I get this why because scare me there's no
insurance in this business you know that dang and
Mike if you don't like it just remember one thing
I've got more guns than you do all right let's
see them we don't have more guns it's my duty
it's hard duty to make castle dead I don't care
what it takes what it costs call the Russian oh
yeah Mr Cash we need your help right now because
the guy who's after Joan is
in her apartment right now
we want you to have dinner with us huh
oh that's sweet sorry I tricked you
hey
you ain't seen food in a while huh it's dessert
come on I need your help uh
oh it's a meat cute a setup
good ones good memories can save your life
come on not yet I'm not what you're looking for
damn it go to him
I don't think it's them [Music] found Waldo yep
whoa if Waldo was a Dolph Lundgren character
[Music] yes dude cool foreign
yeah nice
I love the Trope that being that buff just
just doesn't matter if you get stabbed
oh no [Music] oh geez
yes yeah all right oh
friendship Don't Wanna Die Punk monkey wrench
yes [Music]
whoa no oh my gosh get it go yeah
hahaha nice pose
yes yes oh right through the wall
oh my God this fight
whoa
how does this building work oh they thought
they were neighbors but now are they down
the holler across the way or or is both
possible around good yes oh no dang it
well that sucks oh my goodness he is getting slams
come on help him yeah hot pasta hot
pasta on his head yeah Bernie's face off
[Music]
oh God that looks bad hey you're not gonna like
this guy when he's angry wow I love how much
they're selling the destruction these guys
are gonna have to move out Mr Castle Frank
he's not he's not
he needs a doctor you need a doctor no
hospital no please that's what you want to hear
I like it sure looks like you know
what you're doing Jones not much
where's Castle it's not here really
are you sure what are you doing with all this
stuff what is that sure things do you like that
I heard a little bit there's a special one noon
no wow please don't I was worried about this
yep God damn it ah guys coming
no I don't want it yeah second
I saw him I was like they're gonna do
something with these piercings I hate it
doesn't have to be this way
look like you know about pain
[Music]
I opened up the lens on that stuff if [Music]
when he shows up kill him you have to know by
now that that is not enough right just to be like
hey they have not learned their no one's had been
on the program of killing this you should kill him
I got a bright idea why don't you kill this guy
wow all of them all of them I I figured it must
be but yeah say a big old thank you to Dave yeah
yeah I mean like he did not need
to keep his mouth shut right yeah
he kind of has only known you
for a couple seconds for real
yeah go for that let's do it let's
do yank that thing off [Music]
[Music] yeah buddy
nice you don't know me anything bro you're nothing
but trouble why are you ready to die for me
either one of us oh your family oh
you kill them all what
makes you any different from
some to lose woof the boot camp
Sergeant made us recite It Like a Prayer
sick this pocon Parabellum if you want
peace prepare for war sir Joan or Joan
you listen to me you said let's do a glass just
come out it'll be easier yeah it's the mid-2000s
you'll be okay-ish okay ish yeah I was detailing
Mrs Saints card I found this ticket where was it
the ticket September 5th last Thursday
that was when your buddy was there
oh they probably set it up to put
the wife's clothes in there huh
oh the earring nice subtle touch in the
bed good long game damn all right car
ticket the hydrants earrings now he's just taken
care of by the boss what are you doing here you
know Jim Bowie the colonel the man who died
in the Alamo had a knife named after him he's
a gambler Bowie knife I'm not following this I'm
choosing you oh boy My Life True if you're gonna
do it next time the Windham what you talking
about oh nice body check it's in a funny hour
oh Wowie what do you think I'm an idiot have
you lost your mind ah oh my brother I gave you
everything tonight for nothing you might live who
is she tell you just tell him tell him you are gay
oh man damn that's gonna wreck you for a long
time when those pictures come out with him and
his boyfriend dude yeah just lost your right hand
for nothing he went to the movies last Thursday
eight o'clock yes then at nine o'clock he called
him from your car there's an explanation oh I know
[__] my best friend that would be a little
hard to accomplish Howard oh she knows I was gay
you just talked to me all right first time I saw
you was only three bucks for me now it's just for
she'll fit right in uh dude so evil come on guys
you gotta just throw the pictures his way because
she didn't really do anything she kind of was
like killed the whole family though I mean she
did order the holes yeah I found that in quinton's
bed does that make enough sense for you huh oh
God me neither ew oh wow
yeah okay that's done with
jeez a lot of people getting hit by moving
vehicles in this no no don't grab the track ah you
could have I don't know the logistics of hiding
under a train but I feel like she could have
she could have maybe done it if she just would
have turned perpendicular I mean parallel fifty
thousand a piece and 50 000 more to the
man who kills him if you accept this money
you're in till it's over yeah a little bit of John
Wick Vibes sure the clock is ticking yeah Frank
Castle is excommunicado Extreme situations the
law is inadequate in order to shame its inadequacy
it is necessary to act outside the law whoa
this is not vengeance revenge is not a valid
motive it's an emotional response true that
not Vengeance Justice punishment oh sure yeah
[Music]
this is it for a building where is he it's under
all the cars okay I was like that's a lot of cars
ah not bad nice
hey Eddie more champagne on the double ride
the dumb waiter yes cool he's in the bucket
[Music]
all right [Music]
cooking fools
ouch
dang wow oh no get him
that was a very real response
wow that's awesome that was cool God they
really went to town on that particular guy
Come On Son
you won't get to it in time
buddy reads a little harder
his personal mine weighs
eight pounds stretched arm
oh geez oh my no workout sure nice
punishment I hope we come back after
the credits and his arm is like a huge boss
took everything for me you killed my son
my son
was in a place he wasn't supposed to be
foreign Showdown
yeah where'd you kill your best
friend full circle nice damn
made you kill your wife
oh that's painful oh my God
wow and now I'm gonna drag you
all over town oh wow [Music]
oh no
oh man [Music]
wow
oh cool
oh look it's Mr Myers again oh we
didn't get a close-up no stunt double no
I feel like we should be
playing that that classical oh
I was taking a lot of planning oh my God it's
been sitting there sketching out like what which
color stories do I need to bomb my control the
spread of the Flames oh so I don't get the teeth
right this is so good it's like when Batman did
that whole like big flame bat Dark Knight Rises
Miss Joan
oh
maybe you want to live after all yeah remember
your new family you're right good memories can
save your life when Dave gets out of the hospital
check the cupboard I left something you're leaving
I have work to do read your newspaper
every day you'll understand oh geez wow
which section the punishing one obituaries
nice now you guys can fix that dump up yeah
oh
dude all right you guys never have to work again
question is is he gonna get those piercings
replaced eventually or just let it of course he
will it's part of his personality that's true
how much is it yeah [Music] yes
uno dos tres one for ichia very cool good
for them I'm gonna miss those guys these
sunsets I can't yeah beautiful and you
know they had to shoot them for real yeah
those who do evil to others The Killers psychos
sadists you'll come to know me well ah
Frank Castle is dead call me Punisher
God keep that crane steady
sorry it's what this music is made that was good
oh my goodness Tara Erickson we finally saw the
Punisher yeah wow wow wow wow that was so much
fun I can't that was a blast which yeah would
you think oh it's great I loved it like I need to
go and buy a Punisher t-shirt right now because
I have a new I have a new found just like yes
you're gonna be rocking the punishment oh yeah
Kevin feige got a credit man he was already
working on this stuff way back in the DIA
this was fun yeah it was fun I mean like it's
weird you know knowing the Punisher as a character
and and seeing you know at least you know being
familiar with the show and stuff like that you
have an idea of of what the oh Conrad Hall shot
this nice uh you have an idea of of the sort of
movie you're getting into and this has that but it
wasn't exactly what I was expecting exactly like
it's certainly an action movie there's a lot
of Carnage and and violence and stunts and a
body count but it's not like as extreme and like
just middle the whole time as as you would maybe
expect you know like the John Bernthal Punisher
is like oh I love that show it's great and it's
like it's harsh and and like yeah there's a
different quality to like who Frank Castle is
here and it feels kind of like indicative of yeah
an earlier you know period of this kind of movie
and these Comics adaptation to the screen and
uh it's been interesting because uh what does
it mean Roxy have been watching the Blade movies
which started in the late 90s and go through the
2000s and then this is like the early 2000s and
like watching this this has definitely like a it
feels yeah like we were talking about it has that
kind of like 90s sort of breathability where like
again I don't I don't know like what the the most
definitive version of the origin is but this felt
kind of like the right especially for the moment
in time balance between yes this is an action
movie it's got all a lot of the comic book you
know uh aspects and motifs and stuff like that
but like at the start of the movie I was like you
know oh this is like this is starting out like
it feels like I'm watching face off or something
like that where it's like you have this sort of
steady build of the circumstances like I don't
know I guess I I initially had expected the kind
of movie where you would start out on some kind
of Massacre of his family and that's like the
prologue right and then the rest of it is like
yeah this really harsh like grimy gritty thing
which you know might come you know in later movies
or like war zone or you know but uh but yeah this
was this was a neat like Time Capsule because of
that because it has I guess what I'm trying to
say is like it has all that punisher-ness but not
exactly yeah as like roided out of an experience
as you might expect yeah they took their time more
at the top with like the family setting it up that
it was like oh let's just see him in his like five
language setup like setting these guys up right
using all of his skills that was John Pinette of
course uh uh bimbo or whatever his name was like
he's so freaking funny oh my God I've seen his
stand up a million times I was trying to place
him he's great um but yes continue sorry uh
no it's all good I mean he's he's great uh
what was I saying oh yeah I was just saying
that they have a more of the setup at the
top which yeah it's it's like oh okay we get to
see him with his skill set and setting up these
people and then cut to the family and seeing
like the origin of the T-shirt yes uh was is
pretty awesome that it comes from like his son
so it has this sentiment attached to it yeah
um is that a comic comment below is that a comic
accurate detail yeah I I mean I would love to know
I'm like unless they just add that in the only
one thing that I thought was really weird in this
movie is that when they go they put him and her
down below in the when they're uh interrogating
Dave yeah and she's covering his mouth I'm like
well why he wouldn't know how to be quiet like
right like he's making too much noise occasionally
going uh that's the only thing unless you would be
like fighting her like I'm gonna go up I I would
understand the sentiment of him saying I'm gonna
go up and I'm gonna freaking kill him like
don't touch Dave don't touch my friends yeah
that was the only one weird thing and she kept
covering his mouth that he looked passed out
um any other than that I love the freaking movie
but you guys know me I always point out the weird
things I'm like this one weird thing I don't
know it's in my head hey other than that he's
self-terror the car stunts were freaking amazing I
love the low angle catching every car go over like
a hump or flying in the air there was obviously
a style to it where you can catch more of the
height from a lower angle with the cars and I
thought that was dope yeah the one thing that
the Michael Myers masks were awesome but that
one was a little obvious where I'm a little
I don't know I'm like oh couldn't they just have
thrown like a couple thou at it to be like make
that not look like that yeah slightly frequently
so you can't see the the mask the mask yeah it's
either yeah it's either a dummy or an actor
like with yeah protective mask or something
I think it's a dummy It's gotta be right I mean
that was the only other thing but the stunts in
this were awesome they were like they were they
really again I guess that's it it's like you know
it's not it's definitely got a lot of action
it's definitely got a lot of deaths and stuff
like that and a lot of you know like gratifying
Revenge not Vengeance punishments punishments
um but yeah it's like when there are action scenes
going down they are like so there's just like so
much destruction and and yeah like in the car
chases they're really like visceral and the way
they're capturing them you just feel the weight
and the kind of I don't know like how much damage
these vehicles must be taking on and then all
the physical stunts do too like all those fights
and especially like you know the more you're like
wrecking a room like when they're in uh his place
and that big wall though guys yeah beat the crap
out of him and throwing them through walls and
and through railings and and like there's so many
physical elements that get destroyed throughout
all this like really sells the studs and you're
like yeah this all this just looks painful yeah
and even though it's not necessarily the kind
of movie poised to give you like a million money
shots like they do have a good amount of like
distinct kills and uh and yeah they build the
stakes of like you know I don't know if this uh
Saint character is necessarily like you know a
prominent comic book villain for The Punisher
he's not like jigsaw necessarily where he's
like big and outlandish but you know like he he is
certainly hateable and I loved watching Frank like
really like in a long game sort of way dismantle
and ultimately destroy his entire higher operation
and yeah like you know on the heels of having his
family Massacre then he makes him do it by his own
hand essentially is is super smart yeah it's like
personal and harsh and skin nasty I was so glad
when those pictures came back I was like yeah he's
gonna regret that so hard and then they did at the
very end with the earring I was like oh that's
awesome well that too because because the thing
is you know again with takes on The Punisher and I
haven't seen every Take On The Punisher but uh you
know I think you you imagine that it's gonna lead
with physicality with big guns with Carnage but I
liked here that certainly while he's physically
capable he's also like smart and a tactician and
he's good at like sizing up who he's going up
against and using all that stuff against them
and using their own hubris and all that stuff
to ultimately really seal their downfall and
playing yeah their own deceits against each other
like I love that at first you're like what's this
thing with the fire hydrants and the car and
pretty soon you're like wow oh yeah he is so
smart save that spot spin this lie yeah yeah and
then watch it come back later and uh yeah like
the prologue of the movie I was I was like are
we watching the right film right now because I'm
not as familiar with the idea that he's like you
know an undercover FBI guy doing this stuff but
it was fun to see like yeah Thomas Jane like in a
totally different mode playing this like I don't
know I can remember he's like Russian or German
or whatever um you know like it starts out more
like an earlier movie adaptation too where you
feel like okay we've kind of taken it and made
it like I feel like nowadays you get like a John
Bernthal who looks like freaking huge and like he
could you know beat the [__] out of anybody and
like Thomas Jane he's fit certainly he's muscular
in this you believe everything he's doing but
he's not like so giant and yeah he's not like
built like some machines so it's like even though
there are aspects of this where I'm like I wonder
how like you know people would view this in terms
of like being a definitive Punisher or not but I
thought this really nicely split the difference
between being like you know a film of its time
but also very much translating so much of the
source material of the Punisher you mean yeah
exactly like it doesn't necessarily feel like
you know it's not a one-to-one to what they do
with like the the John Bernthal show or anything
like that but uh but yeah I don't know it felt
like it breathed and moved and had scenes like
an actual movie from this time uh and so yeah
it I'm just fascinated by that because we have so
many of these kinds of movies and adaptations now
and there are you know stylistic earmarks that
can feel very sort of requisite or alike in the
current days sort of superhero movie complex but
uh I don't know going back to these little time
capsules is great because I don't know yeah
again this this does you got John Travolta in
here and like yeah kept reminding me in little
ways sort of of a movie like face off it's not
quite as long as that but you know it's that same
thing of like this this conflict based on a very
personal sort of death or Massacre and then yeah
watching these two guys sort of cat and mouse each
other until it comes to this final showdown and uh
yeah I thought it was nicely handled like it was
is it interesting it was like it wasn't exactly
what I expected but it was like the right amount
of what I expected yeah and like the the
one part that I think they could have done
a little bit more of because I'm like the stunts
in this are so awesome that I'm like come on the
wife and the son you have a car behind you and
there's water jump off the sides and have the
cars like hit them and have like the body fall I
don't know do some cool stunt thing I know that
they probably in their head they wanted a shot
where he's holding them because it makes it for
like engaging for the audience but I always think
like comic panel I just want I always want it to
be like make the every single person in this like
smart that they know how to like outskirt death
a little bit like we all would um I just was like
oh that would be that would make him extra mad if
like the wife was like in half over the edge
that's bad that's just me and my brain going
somewhere because I'm like don't you think they
would have thought just jump in the water anyway
um the next my favorite favorite shot was when
knife goes through that guy's mouth and he's
just like that guy that's so awesome uh he must be
like a pro I recognize him I feel like that I've
seen him in movies as maybe just as stunts but
maybe that's why they spent time on him because
you're like they spent time on that guy yeah
he got the special treatment in terms of like
horror he gets he got the good shot he gets the
the cheek slice the mi2 cheek slice early on and
then he gets like all of the knives later yeah
yeah and a close-up shot of his face yeah and
the knife goes through which is really lovely in
my opinion sure oh my gosh and the the pull-up
of the crane in the shot over the head of the
cars with the Punisher like in Flames come on
man that's so comic book and like uh awesome
and that's and it's like the right amount of
cheese that's the thing is like I feel like
a little corny but great yeah yeah yeah and
it works again for like for 2005 for the kind of
movie we're going with and for the the fact that
like these movies too have just a different sense
of humor and I feel like that is you know a bit
humorous in its height you know he had to clearly
have mapped out this you know fire skull but yeah
it's like it's just the right pitch and it makes
it really fun and this movie I think manages to
nicely occupy a space where yeah it is kind of
harsh and there is like some bleakness to it but
it's not like too dark to where it's not fun in
a way it is that kind of like more exploitation
movie brand of fun because like you know Dave
and his name bimbo and Joan like all three of
them super charming and I really like them and and
they entered the plot in a very sort of gradual
and and just believable way like I thought this
was kind of gracefully paced in a lot of Senses
minus maybe a couple like harsh Cuts here or there
yeah that there was only one harsh cut which I
everything else was cut really nicely especially
when they go up to when he goes up through the
dumb waiter and there's like the champagne cut to
like guy blood champagne popping off it felt that
that cutting felt like really modern there was
one at the very beginning that I was just like
how did nobody realize like this is a harsh cut
everything else I thought was was awesome but I
thought that the three of them added heart to
the movie yeah in in a way that you you didn't
really see coming you just thought maybe the heart
exists over here and there's there's three buddies
that look out the Punisher but then when it all
comes together and they invite him to to dinner
and Dave is like well the reason I didn't speak
up because we're all thinking that like bro you
met this guy 20 minutes ago kind of like why are
you gonna have your face torn up for him but the
the sentiment is is they live by if your family
that's just how we roll and they of course Very
Much deserve however much money they got in those
even though he has not known them for long these
are the type of people that deserve uh the rewards
that come with standing by a neighbor yeah which I
really liked that they got that reward yeah and
I believe that that Bond happening of like even
though yeah we don't know each other super well
there's something about this ragtag group like
they all just felt like they kind of congealed
because they wound up at the same building and
sort of bonded just despite all the circumstances
and so I thought that nicely kind of allowed them
to have the will they won't they with him and Joan
and then It ultimately doesn't turn into anything
but that feels appropriate and so uh yeah just
like a lot of nice little flourishes and things
like that a lot of great character actors across
this uh uh the guy who played glass especially
the guy who played Mickey I've seen them in a few
other things as well and uh and and like yeah that
too like him doing the whole blowtorch popsicle
oh yeah you forgot about that like that was such
a great little gag so great yeah yeah all of it I
enjoyed this quite a bit I'm curious to hear what
people's responses are because yeah I feel like in
the Modern Age you expect uh it's just something
like more kind of thrasher punishing and thrashy
and balls to the walls and just car Carnage on
Carnage and this is definitely an action movie
but it's not like overwhelming you I feel like it
knows well enough and it's from a time where it's
like yeah let's let's breathe this out let's build
some steaks let's Mount some things so that when
stuff really starts to pop off you feel it and you
want that catharsis of the punishment yeah yeah
yeah yeah well you got any extra stray thoughts
before we get out of here I had a blast man no man
this is good old times and I can't wait to get my
Punisher t-shirt even though John Burns out like
a show I loved that show I was like oh I'm in it
but like why didn't I get a t-shirt then dude
you're not a you're a fake fan Tara I know man
well now I know because I was like well I hadn't
watched this one so like I wasn't about to buy
a t-shirt when I knew there were other Punisher
things out there that I have not watched so not
really am I a fake fan I'm a smart fan right I'm
not trying to no I'm not trying to walk around
the T-shirt being like I watched the show but
I didn't watch that movie from 2004 so like I
just leave those out of it because I want the
T-shirt now and I don't want to have to say that
I've got three other movies I gotta get to before
I can wear the T-shirt the next time you see Tara
Erickson she will be in a Punisher team three of
them absolutely all at once well guys leave us
your thoughts on The Punisher leave a like on the
video tell us what you are interested in seeing
next and uh and hey how do you feel about Thomas
Jane in the role I guess I guess before we get out
of here we should at least touch on it I liked him
a lot yeah yeah yeah like he's uh I thought his
he did the transition really well because
you believe him as like you know happy
family reunion guy ex-military but not like
2x military to the point where you're like
this guy is is just that always you know yeah and
then when it transitions into him you know really
having his life torn down like I almost had that
sort of robocop-esque kind of tragedy where it's
like oh man they're just going like so hard on
this guy and his whole family and they're like
shooting him up and yeah I thought he like did
a really nice job of of anchoring this I feel
like people don't bring up his portrayal as much
and certainly John Bernthal kind of towers above
everything now but I thought he did a really
nice job with this and and yeah like I feel
like he's a bit like of an understated kind of
choice but I really liked his presence here and
and that short he did it was this short called
laundry day um they got some pretty yeah there
was a period of time where uh I think his name
is Artie Shankar he was like producing a bunch
of like really Pro ass fan films fan shorts and uh
Thomas Jane came back for that so I'm glad that he
at least got the respect uh from that nice yeah
yeah I thought he was awesome and I was like oh
I need to watch a TV show that he's in because
now I see his face and I'm like he's a lead in
a TV show right now and I don't know what the
TV show is but I gotta watch it they're like by
the beach and he has guns yeah pretty sure and
there's like another lady he's gonna lead with
you guys can leave it in the comments and yell
at me where he belongs on the beach with guns
and a lady exactly because yeah he's one of those
actors too where I feel like there was a moment
where it seems like oh man this guy's gonna star
on a bunch of stuff and then he yeah and then he
didn't continue that but he's like in in he still
continuously has worked yeah and he'll these days
he keeps showing up in places where I'm like oh
[__] Thomas James in it and he's always really
every time I see him I'm always like he leaves
an impression he's really good he's very good
at what he does guys leave us your thoughts on
The Punisher leave us a comment with your wishes
leave a like on the video and hey last but not
least before we get out of here let's do a page
Chris Wham off Chris listen buddy I know we
often talk about how good of a guy Chris is
like one of the best people really he's out here
always looking out for folks a participant in his
community Chris is an altruistic caring person all
right I mean I'm just gonna take John's word for
it but I'm not gonna say that I truly believe it
because I haven't met you yet Chris okay that's
the thing though is is you don't know where the
line is with Chris you know he could become the
Punisher if pushed far enough wow and uh I don't
I mean I don't wish that upon you but at the same
time I'm like what would it be like if pretty
cool because I don't think yeah just knowing
who you're what your moral compass is like I
don't think you would take it out on everybody
I feel like the people who need to be taken out
he takes out that's what Chris does that's what
Chris does yeah he knows he knows good guy you
stay good guy stays bad guy goes yeah so even
at the brink of nihilistic despair I feel like
you would still have a good grip on the moral
compass and uh Hey if you showed up and you were
like you know it's time to accept your punishment
I'll probably be like yeah you know I trust your
judgment Chris I probably have done some heinous
things so uh you know I I just do what you got
to do and make it for me I'd be like and it's
time for you to accept yours no so then it would
be a Face-Off between me and you Chris it could
be his arch nemesis villain guys it's time for a
lady Punisher lady Punisher Punisher put me in it
man punish watch my reels they're on YouTube all
right I'm telling you that that genre of film that
fits perfect for me it's so bad Miss Punisher
put me in it come on now Chris if there's a
Miss Punisher that comes out and they don't let me
audition I'm gonna write that comic so that Tara
has a star vehicle thank you so much that's how
you avoid this this life language but anyway we
love you buddy stay pledged and uh we'll catch you
next month thank you for all your support and for
being a good human a bright light and a shining
example to us all much love buddy we did it